lentement mais sûrement les lyonnais
remplissent à nouveau les rues de la
capitale des gaules
si la place bellecour reste en partie
vide certaines rues commerçantes sont
bien fréquenté c'est notamment le cas de
la rue de la république l'une des
principales artères de la ville
plusieurs boutiques rouvrent leurs
portes après presque deux mois de
fermeture en bas ça fait plaisir de ça
fait plaisir de reprendre un petit peu
écrire en effet revoir un petit peu de
monde mais c'est toujours angoissant
voilà de savoir comment va être le
lendemain autre effet du déconfinement
les vélos et les voitures se disputent
le bitume côté transports publics
la ville assure avoir remis en service
85% des capacités du réseau
mais les habitants ne se bousculent pas
dans les métros bus et tramways
la plupart des passagers respecte
cependant la consigne du port
obligatoire d'un masque de protection en
millions et demi d'exemplaires sont
d'ailleurs distribué gratuitement dans
plusieurs points relais comme l'atrium
de l'hôtel de ville pour certains
lyonnais
la municipalité a trop tardé à prendre
cette initiative
la ville de lyon
qui voulait être sur 10 ans la première
ville de france n'a absolument pas donné
de masques actuellement à cagliari de
maisons déjà avait lieu il ya plus de 15
jours
et là il ya des gens qui sont partis
travailler qu'ils n'en avaient pas le
déconfinement fait également le bonheur
des sportifs nombreux à pratiquer le
long des quais malgré une météo maussade
de leur côté des catholiques peuvent à
nouveau se rendre dans l'emblématique
cathédrale saint-jean réaménager son
mobilier a été retiré en attendant
l'autorisation de pouvoir célébrer à
nouveau les messes le premier ministre
s'est dit prêt à étudier la reprise des
offices religieux
à partir du 29 mai au lieu de la date du
2 joueurs précédemment évoqué